[Music]
Sergio de Mello the world's mr. Fixit
all right everyone let's get together
was powerful official and you in history
now the question is what to do with all
that power my work is in the field where
people are suffering or people need out
so those want to see in Iraq they can
send anybody else it doesn't have to be
you it's not is it for me to do irony
else in this country for you whose
mission requires if ever best doesn't
look very welcome this is Baghdad says
you you still think you can walk away
after four months I do
[Music]
you hear me
are you okay Jesus Christ your says you
deny remember what happened I know what
I want for my life sir here what do you
want for yours both together everything
we're going public can't do that Sergio
you're here to support the u.s. that's
the only reason you're here reason I'm
here too because we're broke it you have
no idea how to put it back together is
the UN just to cover for the American
occupation no suggest for a second we
are here supporting the United States or
the coalition
and he just stay with me I have
survivors do you copy
we're running out of time you need to
leave the area
[Music]
[Music]